we have Duane dog Chapman first sit-down
interview since he lost his wife Beth
just 15 days ago after a long battle
with cancer she was his wife his co-star
his best friend and his confidant Beth
was just 51 years young when she passed
away so for Duane our interview was in
many ways therapeutic because for the
first time he had a chance to release
all the pent up emotions about losing
the love of his life
[Music]
you know you walk in this house in a
sense she is right here with us now is
it yeah I hope so
yeah yeah and then what's in that pink
box well I've never done ashes of my
life and that's what she wanted and
there's chips in their bra hmm I'm like
what is these t oh my god what if you
want you to do with those ashes
well she said scatter some leave some on
the fireplace I was gonna do all the
scattering I did you know and then I
looked at it thought I'm not gonna throw
you like away I just throw you away it
started over and I can't do that I'm
still putting the pillow where she was
and covering it up like the jailhouse
escape hmm right that's like morbid you
know like like it you got to really
watch it these are the times where
people go over the edge the wounds are
still very raw as dog welcomed et into
the family's remote Colorado home that's
a Rocky Mountains could only imagine
on Saturday there will be a huge public
memorial near best hometown of Denver
the grief has taken a huge toll on the
66 year old bounty hunter
I've lost 17 pounds in about two weeks I
got to force-feed myself like I
force-fed earth it could keep going to
keep going do you remember her last
those last moments every every other
time all the time I did not know this
was going to happen that day at all no
one knows this right now
the last few moments she said come in
here right now at the bathroom I went
and she said look at me Wade Chapman I
did she said please let me go before I
could say all right she couldn't breathe
the mother said honey I can't breathe so
she says yeah I can't I can't breathe
and what do you do I help put her arms
up above her head and then I saw her die
in my arms she was so tidy she fell back
my knee was behind her back and I
grabbed her hair and I pulled it up and
I just took one breath and breathes as
far as I could and as I all of a sudden
she went it's she sucked back and I'm
like oh my god so you thought she's
gonna be better you said oh yeah you
were like she's gonna make it oh yeah
and then I carried her to the bed and
called 9-1-1 here they come baby and
they finally got there we rode the
ambulance
after I seen power she went slow
I said Lord I figured it out I wanna go
fast when the show comes back how much
of Beth's final days in her battle will
you show you will hear that answer
tomorrow it may surprise you and also
everything Beth and Dora in her final
days with the Wainwright by her side
it really is heartbreaking and he also
gave me this shocking revelation
I would never commit suicide but I am
ready now to go his grief is total and
we'll have that for you tomorrow
[Music]